we have to figure this out and make a
decision and that's why i keep saying
you're going to see
the ball is in her court the decision is
in her hands 100 percent
and it was pretty early on when we
started thinking
we may have to make a change here and do
something pretty drastic
do not ever talk to me like that i mean
should we
send out a search party for dale i don't
know in moments like this i wish dale
was here
like when i get quality time with her
like
it's a rap if you already got a
boyfriend what am i doing here
right hi okay
chris harrison we really do have so
many questions this was a wild episode
of television
where would you rank this one both on
this season and
just in general in the entire history of
the show
i think in the mount rushmore of
episodes it's up there
it's on the mountaintop for so many
reasons they are there are about four or
five things throughout this show that if
one of them happened in a season you
would say
that's great uh but it all happened in
one episode
and as wild as this one was this is week
three
week four is even more incredible so
these two episodes i think will
definitely go down in the history books
i really don't think i can sit there and
go you've dished on my fiance so hard
like like i can't be doing that well i
feel i have a very clear idea of what's
going on now because
last night claire called dale her fiance
did you say it claire i do you have a
very clear idea of what's going on
i i don't know i it's clear to me
it's clear to me how claire feels about
dale but
why would claire call dale her fiance
was there an off-camera proposal that we
didn't see
that i promise you did not miss there
was not a proposal
that did seem a little presumptuous
maybe
a little overly optimistic of things to
come
i don't know but yeah i thought that was
pretty shocking and again
those are the types of things where we
wanted to show you where her head is at
and there was a lot of dale talk and a
lot of even when she was on date
with other men she was talking about
dale and what did dale say and what it
was
it was a little like not to be demeaning
but almost school girl-ish of
does he like me what did he say about me
what's going on um
it was very interesting to see how she
reacted to the other guys
i feel like i just met my husband
oh my god did you say you think you may
have just met your husband
yeah you uh on that first night when she
said
i think i just met my husband we see you
come over her to her and say
i've never heard a lead say that before
on night one tell me more about just
where your head was at being the
longtime host of this show as you're
seeing her
now call dale her fiance and say maybe
this is the shortest season ever
what's going through your mind had a
lead ever fallen so hard so fast before
i honestly like to think that i have a
pretty good poker face because i've been
doing this for a while and i think it
was you
that called me out on not having a very
good poker face this season
because that did shock me um but
quite honestly the first night i went in
more of just to
capture that moment and lean into that
moment not because i thought it would
go this direction and go this severely
in this direction
i kind of thought this will be good
because we won't be going in this
direction in just another week or two
i mean this will be interesting that she
was falling so hard for this guy and
felt so strong
yet here we are on this other path
because that tends to be what
happens that's not what's happening here
um and and that was just the tip of the
iceberg and it's only gone more
severe in that direction and so you know
i go back to that a1 and go wow
okay maybe she was onto something and
maybe she really did feel that strongly
well we've seen i mean we haven't seen
how it all ends
but we have seen that these guys so far
don't seem super happy
they're frustrated with how much time
claire is spending with dale
what should claire have done differently
if anything with them
do you think they were right for wanting
to walk out
you know i i think that's another thing
that everyone's going to have to sit
back and judge for themselves when they
see
all of this play out and again next week
will be very enlightening for all of
this
i definitely am not disappointed in
claire i'm not mad at claire
none of this is a bad thing if claire's
falling for somebody
and that's where this goes then great
like the whole purpose of this
is to help claire find love and if we
help claire find love
great if i do it in record time that
should go on my record that should be a
good
um so that that there shouldn't be a
negative to this now the guys aren't
dumb
you know if you're dating somebody and
you're trying to get to know somebody
and you feel brushed off you feel like
they're kind of ignoring you they feel
like
she's bringing up another guy nonstop
look these are smart men they're not
dummies they're going to notice this
and so it was a little off-putting i
don't blame them for being frustrated in
this situation they came for
what they thought was a certain journey
and they're not getting that experience
and so i understand their frustration as
well
so claire ends up giving herself a rose
so right now i feel like this rose
um i won't be able to give this out
tonight claire
thank you for showing up tonight you
tonight
deserve this rose you helped
refresh my memory is that a franchise
first
yeah another first um
that wasn't a great look um
she was on the group date had talked
about dale
ad nauseum and these guys just wanted a
chance they were really frustrated they
needed
and maybe she didn't know and to her
credit or maybe in her defense
she didn't know they needed a token to
say hey i'm still here you know you
still have a shot
but these guys were looking for any sign
if she'd given it to anybody
if she had given it to one of our
producers at that moment it would have
been a good sign
but instead she walked away and they
didn't see this but we did when she kind
of laughingly said
i'm giving myself the rose tonight so
that
wasn't a great look um i will admit
what makes you say that did it feel
unfair to them
i just knew the guys were frustrated
these are good men and they really are
putting their heart in this and so
i felt you know they weren't getting
this experience they're trying to lean
into this and you have to take a leap of
faith it's a lot and i get
this is clear season of the bachelorette
so she
holds the reign she is driving this bus
it's all her
and i you know need you look any further
than that you know keeping that rose and
giving it to herself she's making these
calls
it's just these guys have all also
really given up a lot to be here and i
respect that too and so
i just wanted them to have a fair shot
and you could
very very clearly see on that date
they're not getting that shot anymore
well take me behind the scenes a little
bit
was it when claire just gave herself
that rose that you realized
you might not be getting a full season
of the bachelorette
hey we are getting a full season of the
bachelorette you're going to get 13
episodes of the bachelorette
but when we thought this may take a turn
was pretty early on um i was trying to
think if there was really a light bulb
moment or an aha moment it wasn't
necessarily
i'm giving myself the rose i think it
was a culmination of things
where as producers we thought wow this
is this is really coming to a head
quickly
and i think our first thought was well
this will continue on
and it'll ebb and flow like normal
seasons but when we realized
there was only ebb and no flow we
thought
we need to look at what we are going to
have to do
because we do want to deliver an entire
season uh and
what i meant by that was the guys aren't
happy
you may not end up happy like we can't
just just keep going and faking this
along we have to figure this out and
make a decision
and that's why i keep saying you're
going to see the ball is in her court
the decision is in her hands 100
and it was pretty early on when we
started thinking we may have to make a
change here
and do something pretty drastic you end
up
having to intervene at one point you end
up having to go
on claire's dinner portion of her date
with zach
after i think a confusing and an
uncomfortable
day for them sorry to uh barge in
um but unfortunately
claire's not coming to dinner
i mean there was a misunderstanding
there and
i don't know how that possibly happened
why did you end up breaking up with zach
for claire and had you ever done that
before
you know i was trying to think back
you know i've asked people to leave i've
told people it's not working out
but no in that type of situation like
showing up to a date
instead of the lead i've never gone to
break up with somebody
the reason why and you kind of hit the
nail on the head
that awkward incident in the pool
earlier
and that miscommunication that
misunderstanding
there was no coming back for that claire
clearly saw
zach was not the man for her that was
not going to happen he was not going to
go further than that there was no reason
to go through that dinner
there's no reason to put anybody through
that dinner for her to go fake it
and just not give him a rose and for
zach to try and put himself out there
and try and fix it
um and there the the damage had been
done at that point he wasn't getting
that rose
we thought why do this why take
advantage of this scene and drag it all
out when
this guy's just going home and so i just
stepped in and said let's just be done
with us and go
our separate ways and and i don't think
there was any reason to
extend that uncomfortable moment for
anybody uh to perform in that situation
to put him in that situation
there was no need and so it was just an
easy decision to go in and say
hey let's just end this right now you're
not getting a rose she's not showing up
you know it's time to take a moment say
your goodbyes but uh yeah to step in
like that
the way i did and that that type of a
date situation that's the first time i
think i've done that and it's true by
the way we don't eat the food
so let's get to the reveal at the end of
this episode
i jumped out of my seat we don't have
any words we just get tasha
coming out of the pool just talk to me
about what that signifies why
show it that way what does that mean for
the fans and what's next
a confirmation she is our second
bachelorette
um i think you can definitely start
leaning into the fact that things
might be turning around soon does it get
exhausting for you to dodge these
questions are you tired
no i can bob and weave all night i got
this i've been doing this for 20 years
my bob and weave is strong in all
seriousness
this is why i love my entire team from
the producers
to post department to decide and it was
all them to decide to
put that easter egg at the end a la
james bond
halle berry getting out of the pool
was just jaw dropping and stunning when
i saw it i have never
and this is true i've never re-watched
an episode
so many times as last week's episode i
think i watched it three times
i i just think i was that impressed with
every ounce of that in
the tasha of it all at the end was just
incredible
so what does it mean
it means that i think we're
uh taking a turn i think things are
coming to a head in la quinta and
we're gonna have to look look to the
future
okay a tasha turn well if you were going
to make a change
why would tasha be the right person for
that change
if we were gonna make a change uh why
would tay should be a great
bachelorette because she's incredible um
not only is she stunningly beautiful but
she's kind giving she's an unbelievably
sweet girl she's somebody i've actually
gotten to know
and gotten to be friends with over the
last couple of years
and she is what the show is kind of
predicated on and that is this amazing
woman
who kind of seemingly has it all except
she can't find
love and she really wants to find love
and she's dated and
she's trying and it's just not happening
and so uh you know she is that diamond
in the rough that any guy would be
lucky to fall in love with so when was
tasha's name
first brought up to maybe be a turn
um if indeed we go that route
um i look tasha was always on the table
to beat the backs of red
she was always a fan favorite she was
always
a favorite of the producers and so she
was always on the top of our list
clearly we went with claire and that was
a great choice because
she's done a phenomenal job at falling
in love
but if things take a turn then we may
have to make uh make a turn as well and
make a change
and will it be tasha probably
we'll find out next oh my gosh will we
find out next week
yes i can tell you 100
next week will be very revealing
as we really bring this to a head
and next next week you will get a lot of
answers
in fact you get all the answers you want
next thursday night
remember it's thursday night don't hate
on me there's kind of a big dramatic
election going on
pushed in a couple of days different
type of drama claire has now called dale
her fiance she clearly wants to put a
ring on it
could it be one of your rings very
possibly so
a great segue lz to the manly band's
ring line that i'm coming out with
actually just launched this week
i'm partnering with manly bands you go
to manlybands.com
it's this entire ring line for men it's
men's wedding rings and actually some
that you don't have to be married
they're just kind of awesome
rings um a variety of materials a
variety of looks the thing is
for women there are so many different
looks i'm actually wearing you know the
name of this one
the host i see what you did there
so all the rings in my collection i
named
i might have had help from a very
special someone in my life
there is one that i also love that's
called napa
that's near and dear to my heart because
uh this girl that i adore
we love wine and we love love to go to
napa together
so um it is it's a special ring line in
all seriousness it's very near and dear
to my heart
i've put my heart and soul into this
thing and it's really special
i you know i want guys to look at this
entire ring line and say
i'm going to find not just the perfect
ring but my personality a ring that
definitely speaks to me and i think i
might set a new trend and that is
you're not going to pick one you might
have several rings
you know something may want to wear in a
black tie event if you're feeling
country
you wear a little country ring so we may
have to mix it up now and buy multiple
wedding rings
oh well it seems like a good partnership
for you because
your brand is romance you're always
stylish on the show but why did it speak
to you why was this a product you wanted
to get involved with
in all seriousness because that's what i
do
i do love love i i love weddings
i i love when people get engaged i've
seen so many amazing love stories and
engagements and i know how
how hard it is and so it is so special
to find that and when
mainly bands came to me and asked if i
would be a part of this it was just a
no-brainer and
i was really excited because they really
allowed me to be
really involved in creating these rings
now again the experts took over
the quality is fantastic i didn't make
these rings they are truly
incredible quality and you'll feel that
when you get them but they really
allowed me to create
this spectrum where you can kind of find
that ring that speaks to you
and so go to manlybands.com check out
the chris harrison collection
and look if you don't like my collection
nothing personal there's a ton more
rings to choose from
chris harrison i'm only saying your name
once in this question but claire said
dale's name
42 times in last night's episode a
record
day oh dale dale 100
clearly that's a record